hello everyone this is emily here from
audio science review
there were some requests to do some
tutorials and i thought i'd do a mini
one to explain this concept of a decibel
or db you've heard me use that term many
times
you can go google for it but i guarantee
you're going to be lost
i'm actually not going to try to tell
you exactly what it is
as far as the mathematical concept you
can just go ahead and
google for it but i'm going to tell you
practically how i use it and
unfortunately most people
showing you measurements use it
incorrectly
and as a result it's very hard to
interpret their measurements so
with that i also thought i'd show you my
uh control panel for my audio precision
analyzer
box that's sitting over there as you see
that has no display of its own
the user interface is what you're
looking at over here
i've configured the machine to output
analog output and then i've clicked on
this
loopback meaning that its input is now
connected to its output so it's just
measuring itself excuse me instead of
trying to measure an external device
we're just analyzing the
analyzer itself i've programmed it to
output four volts
and we can see that it's measuring
itself at 3.99
volts so close enough uh i've set it to
one kilohertz i'm using the analog
generator the analog generator has very
low distortion but
uh uh its frequency is not very precise
so you can see that there's got this uh
you know way out there and it's one
kilohertz but
you know i don't know eight uh 100
thousands of
kilohertz or whatever that comes out to
be anyway
you've seen me talk about this you know
sign ad in this decibel
and uh the analyzer right now is has a
sign out of about
122 db but if we look over here
uh where we've taken the spectrum
analysis at
a spectrum extracted the spectrum from
uh
this sine wave that's coming out um
if you look in here now you sort of
can't figure out what this graph means
the top of it
is more or less the four volts so that's
four volts up here
but what on earth you know is down here
it says 100 nano volts
i mean that's a very hard concept to
wrap your mind around
it's what's a nano volt and what we can
do with a nano volt
in general when we're analyzing and
measuring things and
this class of devices that i'm measuring
we're not interested in actual voltages
we're interested in ratios we want to
know if our signals up here and our
distortions
down here what is that distance between
the
two of them because then we can use
psychoacoustic research
in telling us how audible that amplitude
is relative to our main signal so we're
always interested in the ratio of these
things
not as an absolute voltage i mean
there's
you know if i raise both of them high
the ratio stays constant that's what
determines audibility
so here we don't have that uh we don't
know you know we could try to do the
math in our head
that's very difficult so what we can do
is convert this thing to
instead of volts we can convert it to
decibels
relative to volts it says dbv hopefully
you can read that
and this is basically saying everything
i'm going to show you on this graph now
is
relative as a ratio to 1 volt
and so
it's showing us a graph now that it's
the numbers now for one thing
look a lot more uh sane now
um and uh
because they're just normal numbers we
don't have nanovolts and and what have
you
and uh we see there's a minus 140 down
here
and so if we look at this spike we might
be tempted to think that this is
at -140 or thereabouts uh turns out
that's wrong
why is that wrong because if we look up
here
the peak of our signal is not at zero
it's actually at 11 or something like
that and
if that's the case then this is not 140
db below that it's uh
you got to take that 11 and subtract it
from this
so it's a very inconvenient unit to use
this dbv
there's a close cousin of it called dbu
it's just another ratio and it's got the
same problem
but yet you see it used a lot in a lot
of measurements
that people show it's just a super
confusing thing
again you can go google for these things
and learn what dbu and dbv are
mathematically just simple formula but
it's just very hard to wrap your head
around it even i can't keep it straight
and what i do is that i avoid both of
these things
i don't care how many volts we really
have as i explained we want to know the
ratio
so there's a clever thing the analyzer
can do is
where i can try to take an
arbitrary voltage and make that the zero
manually and then we can see all the
distortion and noise then
fall under that now i've set it right
now to dbr a which is
db reference an a it's got two of them a
and b
but it's not programmed correctly
because it's still the peak of this
output is above zero but a clever thing
i can do is go over here in references
and i can set that reference to what is
being measured which is this 3.99 volts
right now oh sorry you don't see the
pop-ups over here so
just take my word for it that i'm
setting the dpr reference to uh
four volts now that i said that my
reference to be this
the source signal the wanted signal now
when we look down here we can see
exactly where the uh
uh these peaks are the numbers here now
100 correspond to the uh values that we
want to know from psychoacoustics point
of view
so this signal we can say is minus 148
db
this means um the
peak that you see at 60 hertz and
there's a little distortion over here
minus 150 db i can actually
mess this up by the generator also has a
dac
and instead of using the uh analog
generator
you can use a dac so let me go ahead and
reset this so
now the the digital generator that it
has is generating signal
and you can see it has far more
distortion
like most stacks would and here now we
can read these
so nicely now we can see that this third
harmonic is at minus 115 db
and we look at down here our sine add is
-112
so that's actually pretty close it's
saying that this is basically the
problem area add a little bit of noise
to it which is what this number is
sine hat is sum of noise and distortion
and we get to
1 12. and you see the power of
of using a a log scale or ratio
and also having it set to zero
when this is not set to zero it just
causes nothing but confusion so
my advice so anybody that publishes
these measurements is please please
don't use dba
dbv or dbu
always use db relative and then set that
to be
zero once we have a zero we said we
immediately know how low this amplitude
is
i've explained that when these
distortions are around
-115 means they're absolutely inaudible
and we can see that's the case even
though this is the dirty
generator in my audio precision it still
is
this noise is below audibility
uh so hopefully it's concepts understood
again you can go
google for it online and learn more but
what we're trying to do is have a scale
that's easy to understand
and also be able to cover very high
range of numbers that's what a log
scale is let's do and db is a log scale
in that it allows us to go way down deep
to very very small numbers
yet deal with you know small values like
minus 150 rather than nano volts and
pico volts and
you go down way way way down to numbers
that you can't just wrap your head
around
um i've also mentioned this in the past
that we can take any ratio a
phd plus n which is harmonic distortion
and noise is a ratio
right it's a percentage it says what is
if we add all these together on the
noise what is the ratio to this
you can express that as a percentage but
as you see here is very hard to remember
this number
uh zero zero zero zero two five zero
whatever it is whereas you know
one twelve all right great i can
remember one twelfth that's a lot easier
to remember
and uh let me leave you with a hint uh
before i finish even though we say these
things are decibels don't ever call them
decibels
uh always call them a db now
if you look around you'll see that the
two are equivalent the units we write as
db but this stands for decibel
when you say decibel it
can't imply that you don't know what
you're talking about whereas when you
say
dv sounds like you know a lot more than
you do
so whenever you're walking around and uh
talking to somebody else technical just
throw the word db around
and that person may think that you know
a lot more than you do
but you said decibel is not something we
as engineers usually
spell out so you want to look cool
use db okay see you in the next review
next uh video bye bye